[Musique]
aujourd'hui mais ça va dans une maison
d'accueil ans familiaux à sainte-marie
qui s'occupe de nos drames bah oui ce
n'est la case valentine et c'est super
joli bonnet sa roue ou fait un peu trop
nous sommes un dossier un des grands
moments où ce sont les bénéficiaires jeu
c'est promis je me mêle de mes affaires
justement je dois y aller voir
si vous aussi vous voulez découvrir
comment nos rames sont choqués de la
cale valentine
[Musique]
nous sommes à sainte-marie à la maison
d'accueil familial la catalan tine et
s'ils résident quelques uns de nos
gramounes qu'on aime tant tous sont
accompagnés et soutenus par des
accueillons qui s'occupe bien de 24
heures sur 24 il faut en sorte que nos
aînés apprécié la journée loin de la
solitude et de l'ennui et vu la beauté
de l'endroit je pense qu'ils doivent se
sentir bien ici et justement à l'eau de
montamat dans cette
manière bonjour comment c'était pour
vous avoir 2009 dieu vu avec ma fille et
elle a une fille en france avec ses
petits enfants
donc elle a voulu partir faut passer
quelques mois la barre mais deux garçons
m'ont dit non peux pas te laisser tout
seul on va chercher et c'est la prendre
à prouver ici même vous sentez ici comme
chez moi bonjour à oui et puis on est
vraiment bien occuper très chouchoutés
là rien à dire impeccable et ses pénates
ospel et pourtant on à le manger les
liens morts les professionnels tels que
les infirmiers et toute l'équipe qui
s'occupe de vos novaes génial merci
beaucoup à en faire aux autres pays
merci à vous
cette maison d'accueil familial est géré
par une association du même nom la cale
à nantes in vincent et sa poule et et le
président cette association infirmiers à
domicile de formation hélas pu mesurer
la détresse de certains seniors et a
souhaité leur apporter son soutien
emporte dans ce projet mais sans mon
jour mon jeu comment avez vous envie de
porter ce projet estimé que le domicile
était parfois le lieu qui n'est plus
adapté pour certaines personnes tu
parles pas aux familles qui travaillent
et ce passage vers l'ehpad nous semble
être un trop grand parti je trouvais
intéressant justement de pouvoir créer à
l'intermédiaire aucune maison d'accueil
familial avec les valeurs que je porte
au département effectivement accompagné
sur sur l'investissement pour moi j'ai
déposé un dossier une demande pour
réaliser un projet de maison d'accueil
familial j'ai été accompagné à hauteur
de cent cinquante mille euros pour un
investissement et un budget de
fonctionnement qu'on a demandé où elle a
accompagné pendant cinq ans d'abord
merci beaucoup vincent avoue en plus bas
vous
comme les autres est proposée par le
département cette initiative
volontariste est encadrée par des
experts du domaine est d'accompagner les
gestionnaires pour mener à terme le
projet dans les meilleures conditions
c'est ce que fait et l'audit est chère à
jean viii département spécialisé dans le
dispositif des maisons d'accueil
familial bonjour elle dit que faut-il
faire si on veut créer une maison
d'accueillant stamile ou alors il
convient d'adresser au département une
demande d'accord pour être employeur
accueillants familiaux le département
subventionne les porteurs de projets
grâce à deux types dead une subvention
d'investissement de 150000 euros maximum
et une subvention de fonctionnement en
visant à tendre à l' équilibre de la
structure et qui peut être versé pendant
cinq ans le département accompagne
également les personnes âgées et les
personnes en situation de handicap au
travers des aides individuelles pour
financer leur accueil la maaf est une
réponse à des enjeux importants pour les
territoires notamment le vieillissement
rapide de la population et le besoin de
créer une offre d'accueil diversifiées
et adaptées aux besoins des publics
mairie et le dis merci
pour vous trouver toutes les
informations concernant les maisons
d'accueil familial rendez vous sur le
site du département
www.gpat.ca 4 point fr l'adresse
s'affiche en bas de votre écran voilà le
département des générations d'être finie
vous pouvez revoir cet épisode et les
épisodes précédents en replay sur nos
sites ou sur les réseaux sociaux je vous
donne rendez vous rêvez pour le nouvel
épisode
la semaine prochaine nous irons à saint
leu pour en rencontrer un agriculteur
pays il nous expliquera comment le
département l'a aidé à augmenter son
potentiel
[Musique]